are you under
a thousand subscribers and really want
to figure out how to grow
your youtube channel are you maybe
working a full-time job or in school and
trying to figure out how to do
youtube on the side to grow your
influence your impact and ultimately
make a difference in the world well i'm
excited for today's
think marketing show because myself and
tony from the think media team
are going to be sharing with you one of
the strategies that him
and his wife kami have used on their
channel to be able to
grow to over a thousand subscribers and
today's video is actually brought to you
by our
think inner circle have you heard about
inner circle inner circle
is our monthly group coaching and
mentorship program and the doors are
open right now for enrollment to
this monthly program and i'll tell you
more about that in just a little bit but
i'm excited to bring my co-host on today
tony arioli oh ariola how you doing tony
doing great thanks for that intro
appreciate arioli it's a better name
actually
it's better it's better i like it
awesome well tony you have been on the
think team
for a few months now um and so excited
for your journey here at think media
uh here at think media your role is as a
content producer so you really help us
uh grow the youtube channel as well as
helping us inside of um inner circle and
inside of video ranking academy helping
all of our students that are in there
really learn how to grow their channels
and one thing i'm excited about you uh
teaching the
think marketing show today is about your
own channel
so while you work here at think media
and your wife has a full-time job
you both are running a side business
um called the plant based kitchen and
i'm excited because this
one strategy that you're going to teach
is something that
anyone can apply right right right i'm
really excited again like we've talked
about even in the titleist video
especially if you're under a thousand
subscribers
i'm really excited about the strategy
i'm gonna talk to you guys tonight about
yeah
and hey if you're just joining us right
now hit that like button
and let us know where you're watching
from in the comments section
uh anything we talk about today all
links will be in the description below
so if you want to check out any of these
uh any of the things that we talk about
today we'll make sure that to link
things up below
if you want to go check out other
channels or things like that so hey tony
why don't you take it away and share
that one strategy that they need to
apply if they're under a thousand
subscribers
amazing thank you so much heather now i
don't know if you're like
me but as a kid i remember
the joy of getting up on a crisp
saturday morning
maybe in the summer and going to
the lake to go fishing you know there
was only a few things here in southern
california that maybe got me excited as
a kid waking up early maybe there was
disneyland you know there was other
things but fishing was definitely one of
those things maybe not as cool as
disneyland but it was something that i
woke up and i looked forward to the
forward to the opportunity the
possibility
of what i could the day could happen in
front of me what could happen like i
could catch a ton of fish
i could bring it back home like all
these things as a kid i just have this
fond memory of getting up to go fishing
and maybe some of you are like that with
your youtube journey you're just
starting and you're under a thousand
subscribers
and you're just excited you're excited
about the possibilities the
possibilities of building this
channel that you've dreamt of and that
you've just excited
to build you know but i also remember
these days
as hours spent right trying to catch a
fish and as the heat of the day
increased
you know my energy was just zapped from
my body and
i just remember those days going long
and long sometimes and just realizing
the more i
fished maybe the less chance i had
to catch a fish i would see a little
bobber on the on the surface of the
water and i'd think maybe i'd see it go
under and maybe think a fish would be
there reel it in only to find
that nothing was there and that you know
maybe my bait was even gone and the fish
had
duped me again and maybe you can relate
to this feeling when it comes to youtube
maybe you feel like you've been doing
youtube a long time
you've tried and you tried and you still
have yet to really feel like you've
caught something or that you've gotten
traction and you know it wasn't until a
few years ago
when i um had a friend of mine who is a
professional
fisherman he was sponsored and he does
tournaments
he's a professional bash bass fisherman
he had
the decked out boat had tons of rods had
all the gear had everything that i could
possibly
need while fishing with him he even had
enough for himself
and for me included and he took me into
his boat his nice like
just pristine looking speedboat and he's
like okay
tony i'm gonna take you out and i'm
gonna take you to
the honey hole i remember thinking honey
hole like what do
i mean i don't understand what that term
means there's no honey involved with
fishing they're putting honey on the raw
i mean on the ba i don't know
i'm just totally new to this thing and
he began to explain a honey hole
is where the fish are and what he did
was
he had fished this lake multiple times
and he knew
the spots he needed to go into to get
the fish and so what i want to show you
today
is a youtube honey hole a place
where you can find subscribers and views
that you probably don't know about
because maybe you've been fishing for at
the wrong spot
and you've been spending a lot of your
time spending your wheels trying to
figure this out and so like heather said
earlier
i do work full-time here for think media
my name is tony if we're just meeting
and i also uh do have a little bit of
some side channels that i do manage and
one of those channels is actually my
wife's channel which is the plant based
kitchen and the plant-based kitchen is a
channel
for having vegan food or plant-based
food tastes
amazing my wife is an incredible chef
and she loves cooking and sharing
recipes with people and so we both work
full-time jobs
and we both are trying to build this on
the side
and maybe you're like us as well you're
a full-time you're working full-time
maybe going to school full-time
and you're trying to make this
work here on youtube right and so this
one strategy that i want to teach today
and this one honey hole has produced
some incredible results
we saw in a matter of one month from
this strategy we saw a growth of eight
thousand four hundred and eighty one
percent i mean it's kind of
specific but in subscribers um you know
it is now the channel has now crested
over 2
000 subscribers just started this year
so it is a newer channel
and we saw views skyrocket by 641
percent
in this one month by utilizing this
single strategy so i hope i've piqued
your interest here today because
i want to share this with you guys
because it's something that i've
it's been near and dear to my heart i've
been working on this to help present to
you guys here as a part of the think
marketing audience um here today
and so this one strategy that i want to
teach you guys tonight
is utilizing facebook
groups now don't tune me out here i know
you're going to hear the word facebook
and you're like isn't that where all the
political people talk
isn't that where you know my mom and her
friends are at or my grandma my friends
are at
and i just want to encourage you to lean
into this because this powerful strategy
in 2020 and even beyond is such
a powerful strategy with utilizing
facebook groups
and this is a post in a facebook group
that you can see on the right side here
if you're watching or if you're just
listening i'll read this post to you but
basically
i put a post in one of these vegan
facebook groups
that i talked about just bragging on my
wife just talking about how amazing she
is my wife's been building this super
hard
to build or my wife has been working
super hard to build a youtube channel
for people who want to make delicious
vegan food
all while working full time at her job
which is all true and i was extremely
proud of her
and i shared her channel
with the facebook group that i was in
this vegan
facebook group and this post kind of
went mini viral
in the group and the outpouring of
support on her channel
was unprecedented and people came and
they watched and the thing that was
great about this
is that it was not just people that were
vanity subscribers or
vanity views and you may have heard of
for sub or view for view and
us here at think marketing and in think
media we just do not believe in this
and we don't think it's actually
sustainable growth but this was growth
of people that was her exact target
audience so i want to break down a
couple things for you and you might be
thinking to yourself well man i don't
know facebook groups don't really work
for
my um channel well i want to put out a
couple things to you guys real quick so
i did a quick search of just different
types of groups that could be
that are already existing and already
thriving in
the facebook group community i guess i
would you will have you um the first one
that i found here was for
toyota prius owners i'm a toyota prius
owner and so i've looked up like stuff
when i've had to fix things before
and i've realized there's this thriving
online community
for toyota prius owners and so you can
see on the screen if you're watching and
if you're listening
prius prime owners is a group with
almost 2 000 members ready for this one
toyota prius owners club
23 000 members in that group
it's 23 000 people that just own priuses
and so you can imagine the power of
having your target audience all
collected in one space where you can
deliver them value right we have groups
for homeschooling in southern california
13 000 subscribers our members in that
group we even have
free homeschool ideas 40 000 members
you can go on to minimalist living
minimalist living has a group of 26
000 members and one of my personal
favorite places to go here in southern
california is disneyland it is closed at
the moment but looking forward to when
that opens up again
and you can see right here there's a few
different disneyland groups there's one
called vintage disneyland that's 89 000
members there's
mice chat which is kind of like the
disney like
secret stuff and it's kind of like the
super fans of disney are in this group
mice chat and has 24
000 members you have arts and crafts you
have
rving i mean there is endless
possibilities
for facebook groups and i'm begging to
guarantee you i can't
fully guarantee you but i'm begging to
guarantee you that i think
every channel here watching and
listening would have a facebook group
that would be relevant
for your audience to see your
videos so i hope i feature interest
within facebook groups now i have a few
points for you guys that if you want to
take further action
on this and really grow your channel
using facebook groups
that you're going to need to be aware of
because there are things that i've
learned
that i've been putting into practice and
things i've done the right
way and things i've done the wrong way
within utilizing the strategy and i want
to share
just some of that with you
so the first thing i want to share with
you is the first thing you have to do
right you find these facebook groups
like i just mentioned
and the first thing i want you to do
when you get into these facebook groups
is
answer questions answer questions
so in these facebook groups you will
find posts you will see posts of people
asking questions
you know maybe you're that toyota prius
group there'll be people asking
what's the best tires for my toyota
prius what is the best
brakes you know how do i fix this
problem and if you have a toyota prius
channel
you're there and you can answer those
questions
and so the first thing you want to do
when you enter these groups is comment
on existing posts
that ask a question with a link to your
video
this is the first level okay so i'm
going to show you a couple examples of
this if you're watching if you're
listening you can
listen along as well but we have a post
in one of these groups
that says this okay folks
i need some help my daughter and i have
yet to have a successful
tofu experience i need to hear from the
people that really didn't like it
until please fill me in on one recipe or
method of cooking that changed your mind
please so this is again the plant-based
and vegan community that
me and my wife are a part of and you can
see that she
also commented back to them saying with
some simple answers such as
marinating tofu for sure i have a recipe
for bon
me that has the perfect marinade to use
that's one of her videos is a tofu
bon me sandwich recipe so you see how
she answered the direct question
with a video another answer was also
seasoning is really important and i have
some go-to spices
i use or else tofu can be pretty bland
and she links a video to the best spices
for making tofu taste
good so when you respond to people
here's what happens
when you respond to people like this two
things happen
one is yeah you get people seeing your
channel but the second thing is you're
actually helping people which we argue
here at think marketing think media
is should be the goal of your channel is
to help people
to help bring people along maybe a
journey or something that you're
super knowledgeable about that they're
just starting in
and you're helping them so you're
achieving the mission of
your channel by giving people answers
and if you don't
have a video to an answer i'd encourage
you to also just answer it
if you don't have a video that's all
right but it's also another great
encouragement to you to
continue to build your library of
videos on your channel so you can
continue to recommend them for days
weeks
and years to come and so that's the
first thing you want to be answering
questions and posts with a video link
when possible
the second thing when it comes to
posting
so number two we want to post helpful
content that sounds so generic but let
me break that down for you when it comes
into facebook groups
you want to make helpful posts in the
groups
with complete answers in your post
so let me explain that i want you to
post things
that don't require them to go to your
youtube
you're like wait that's the goal though
right you said i'm supposed to go to a
thousand subscribers
yes that is the goal and yes you can put
a link
to your youtube in the post but i want
to read a couple
examples for you here of what i'm
talking about
so inside of some of these plant-based
groups
we have posted a couple posts in there
these are just some of our
our ones we did last month there is one
that says yummy
vegan fried rice full recipe that's the
key here
full recipe is attached as a photo so
you can screenshot
there's also a video recipe here and
that's where we put the link in
so we give the full value people do not
have to leave facebook to get the full
value of this post
okay that's a really important i would
just
encourage you to really go with this
strategy because you're giving people
value you're helping people that is the
goal of your channel right
another one i love bond me sandwiches i
made this
easy and delicious tofu balmy sandwich
and wanted to share it with you
i attached the full recipe so you can
screenshot it and then the video recipe
link
is right below so it's really important
because
i don't want you going into groups just
putting your link to your video because
i promise you
that's you're using the strategy wrong
you're gonna come back to think
marketing you're gonna find me on
instagram
you're gonna tag me you're gonna go tony
this didn't work well
you have to work it the right way and
what i mean by this is by being a
helpful human being
and not thinking of yourself first
i know kind of mind-blowing you think
i'm supposed to be and yes you want to
grow your business you want to grow your
channel
but helping people first above
everything hear me help people
first above everything okay so helping
them
that is your first goal and so that's
what we're doing with these posts
in these facebook groups and the last
thing i kind of alluded it a little bit
to you earlier but the last thing
is that you have to play by
the rules that's the third thing you
have to do is play by the rules every
facebook group so you have to know your
group's guidelines for posting
some groups have really strict rules
against self-promotion
right and rightfully so because it would
just turn into a self-promotion just
billboard news feed so what i'm
encouraging you to do is not self-promo
i'm encouraging you to be helpful to
people
and give them an option somewhere deeper
in the copy to go deeper with you
if they want to see the youtube link but
here's what i'm gonna encourage you with
is that you're probably gonna mess this
up a little bit you're probably gonna
get maybe get kicked out of a group or
two because
they're not they're not gonna take
nicely to it it's okay just continue to
work this strategy because i'm telling
you right now
i'm in like 20 to 30 vegan facebook
groups and i think i've gotten kicked
out of
one because we were trying to help
people someone asked me for a link in
the comments i responded back to them
and they kicked me out for that so
if that happens to you anyways it's
probably not worthwhile for you to be in
that group anyways because they're not
open for
you being helpful to them with providing
them with content
so you have to play by the rules okay
and
my golden rule like i just said is this
be helpful
above everything okay be helpful
more than anything and so i hope that
was helpful for you today because
you know what i've done for you today
hopefully is this
i've led you to the honey hole you know
i've led you to where the fish are now i
can't make the fish get on
your hook and into your boat on your rod
and reeled in
i can't do that for you but what i can
simply do is say hey
i got a boat i got i got some fishing
rods and i can
show you where the honey hole
is and i promise you if you take massive
action
on this strategy you're going to see
dramatic
results in reaching that ever elusive
1000 subscribers
thank you i'm going to bring heather
back on
yeah that was amazing tony thank you so
much i love that analogy too
it reminded me of when i was little when
i was out fishing and i think you really
hit it and and
people are resonating in the comments it
really is about
being helpful first and when we think
about wanting to grow our audience
you said it best tony it is not about
you it's about being someone to help
them and some people said you know what
about
facebook rules and all of those things
like tony said you want to be
involved in the community you want to be
in there you want to be
seeing what questions are coming up one
because that can give you topic ideas
but two
there's so many times tony where i'm
inside the groups and i actually
don't post my videos per se i answer the
question and i say
hey and if you want more tips like this
i do also have a youtube channel
people love to find people right so
you don't even necessarily have to be
posting just your links
if you're just a part of the community
that is something that brings people
value and that is something that we
actually teach
inside of inner circle and this show
today this live
q a show is brought to you by our think
inner circle which is our monthly
group coaching and mentorship program
where we actually walk you through
10 steps for building your six to seven
figure media company and
tony did you know that our website was
down yesterday
yeah i know it was crazy it was
craziness
the doors for inner circle actually
closed yesterday tony but because
the website was down yesterday because
the website was down yesterday we
actually
thought oops where'd i go we actually
wanted to make sure
uh that if you were wanting to get into
our group
monthly coaching program here at think
that you can do that you can get all the
information at think innercircle.com
this is a paid
monthly group coaching program and so if
you were one of the people who were
trying to get that
yesterday well our website was down and
our team was freaking out
we've extended that offer for you where
you can not only get access to inner
circle
but we've got some really amazing
bonuses like two tickets to grow with
video live
2021 and a couple other amazing things
so
i just wanted to let you know that that
is still open that is what
today's video is brought to you by and
tony
you were actually a part of inner circle
before you even
came on the think team tell me about
your experience
as being part of inner circle yeah i was
i was a part of inner circle
i um joined video ranking academy maybe
like some of you already have
and i remember seeing inner circle
at last year's growth video live and i
remember just thinking you know
i want the ability to see my channel
from a fourth dimensional
place and really see it as a business
over the long term growing
and that's kind of what we're all about
here at think marketing and we go super
deep at inner circle and so me and my
wife we signed up before we even on
staff here before we even a part of the
team we just knew the amazing value that
came from
this team and from this amazing company
and so yeah we definitely jumped on it
as soon as we could and i was so
grateful that you were there tony
because that's how we picked you out of
the crowd right
hey danny's asking real quick tony is
this youtube live or zoom or stream yard
what are we even using here to be able
to do all these fun fancy things
yeah so this is stream yard uh we are
going into
into youtube live from stream yard we
actually have a couple tutorials coming
out
super quick on think media our super
quick soon sorry
on think media in like a month or two
about this but we also have everything
we're using
think media tools as you can see on the
bottom of the screen there you can
actually get started with stream with a
little bit of a discount and stuff it's
just the way we do all of our live
stream shows here
yeah and sasha great question um how
can this work with a lifestyle group
when creating your own
facebook group and you know we actually
have several facebook groups here at
think and tony you run one of our groups
which is vra the video ranking academy
group
um how do you do this how do you go
about this strategy if you are
actually the leader of your own group so
the
the thing is when you're leading your
own group it is definitely
trying to think through the naming of
that group if you're trying to get
organic reach from that group meaning
i'm trying to get people that just find
my group and join it
then you probably want to name your
group something that people are
searching like we teach at video ranking
academy you know like
look up what people are searching and
look at like people are looking up like
how to vegan how to eat vegan and one of
the biggest groups is
called how to vegan and because they
named it that way
it just was very searchable and people
found it but also just pointing to it as
much as you can from
your uh youtube from other social medias
as much as you can
to kind of grow that and then it can be
used even as your own honey hole your
own lake even
of fishing and giving people amazing
value so that's what i'll recommend
and i really love all of the feedback
hey if you're getting value out of this
video today make sure you hit that like
button and you're watching here on the
think marketing channel
if you've not clicked that red subscribe
button
right now is your time to click the red
subscribe button and that just lets you
know when we're going live
uh and when we uh are going to have
season two
of our podcast coming out very soon tony
we have some people in the back end
who are waiting they have some questions
for us um
and again yes you can go to our tools
page
if you're curious about what software
we're using right now we have an entire
tool page built out for you to help you
with
that and just want to thank you so much
for being on tonight we see the sleeping
guy
we see um the costly pearl tell your
story miss kat moon
thank you so much for being a part of
inner circle i see you guys on there
um love that joshua thank you so much
think marketing good stuff thank you so
much
looks like we've got a little crafty on
today and jacob says just curious will
you guys cover
other online groups such as super
reddits tony
yeah that's a great question that's
really funny jacob
is that i could not be more a fan of
reddit uh
especially for gaming channels as reddit
is a really good
hub for that and i would encourage that
if you're
looking the thing is with facebook
groups is this i really believe they can
be for pretty much any channel
but the principle still reigns true the
principle is
that you want to find where your target
audience is hanging out
and where they're asking questions
because that's where you can deliver
value in the form of your video and make
sure
i mean again it's not just
self-promotion it's actually get
connecting people to a helpful resource
that's the key so reddit isn't something
that i've personally done a lot of but i
know
it's a great resource especially in the
gaming community and
especially i think one of the biggest
streamers he actually his name is shroud
one of the biggest gaming streamers and
he grew a lot of his audience initially
from reddit and so reddit is a great
place to help people with practical
questions and practical answers and we
actually had a really good question tony
that came in
about uh what is the difference between
a facebook group like posting on a
facebook group and then actually just
posting on a facebook
page and i get it i mean facebook has so
many different features and if you're
new to
what this looks like as a marketer as
someone who's growing a business
how you leverage those two different
things can you just walk us through what
those two different things are
right um so a facebook page is
it's it's your page so you control
everything
and you can post things you can comment
to other people on things and it'll show
up as your
page um but a facebook group i want you
to think of it as like a community of
people
so someone can make a group and they are
like the caretaker if you will or the
admin
of that group so they kind of like put
the rules in place
they kind of like like kind of put the
guidelines on they kind of can control
the whole group
they can they can kick people out invite
people in
approve people that want to get into
this group and so the group though
is kind of a way of like making the
content
more siphoned like this is the type of
content that's going to be in this group
whether that's like for our channel
that's like the vegan it's only vegan
related topics really
in those groups and so the other thing i
didn't really share earlier is that
facebook
even is favoring in the algorithm groups
so if you even go down your homepage as
you start joining groups or if you're
not in groups already you start joining
them
you're going to see on your home feed
that a lot of group
posts are going to show up and so what
happened with my wife's one of her posts
going kind of mini viral
is it started showing up on people's
home screen because facebook was like
people like this post people like this
post i'm going to show it to more people
and so that's kind of the main
difference that i would say
between groups and a page really great
and i love this planning
planning daisies am i saying that right
tony i think so yeah
okay i wanted to say planting daisies
but planning
uh any places other than facebook where
seniors are more likely to be hanging
out facebook
actually is one of the largest platforms
for seniors
and it's actually one of my favorite if
you are trying to reach seniors because
they use it like no other demographic
tony let me ask you when you're
scrolling through facebook how fast do
you scroll like what does that look like
for you
oh my gosh it's fast yeah it's like fast
that's fast yeah yeah
my grandma's scroll is like this you
remember okay
let me know in the chat if you were ever
in this era
when email first came out and it was
like every time you got an email
you read from word to word
line to line right that's what seniors
are doing
on facebook they are consuming it at
such a
uh such a more intense pace
than say the millennial generation or my
generation um because
we are we are we've got all the apps
we're doing all the things and so
facebook is actually one of the best
places where
seniors are if you want to be uh talking
to them
um so i would say yes planning daisies
stay on facebook
the second platform i would say for you
is actually pinterest pinterest is a big
flat platform but
planning daisies you are here on youtube
so you know my number one answer
for think is going to be your
demographic is on
youtube they are searching on youtube
they are consuming videos on youtube
so you want to be on youtube and
facebook if you are within
that demographic well tony we have some
people who are going to be popping on
tonight uh they have some questions for
us and it looks like
um aiden has a question about growing
groups without an
influence hey aiden how you doing
good how about you good thank you so
much for joining us hey
aydah this is a think media super fan
aiden is on all of her streams
he's always here and aiden's actually
growing a media company
um where he's helping small businesses
learn how to use social media
is that correct that is correct and it's
a great idea to be a part of the think
community
thank you so much aiden so what is your
question for tony and i around groups
tonight
yeah so my question was how can i grow
my facebook group when not everyone is
really
interested i'm trying to grab those
people from the youtube
maybe the instagram trying to get other
friends that maybe are interested in
this no matter
where they might be how can growing my
facebook group no matter
how i'm sharing it how can i grow not
everyone's interested
yeah that's a really good point aidan
and that is really true
everywhere on social media you know here
at think media and think marketing
we have uh well over a million and a
half subscribers across all the channels
that we're doing
and you know not everyone's in our own
facebook groups
so i would say that you want to make
sure that you're creating the right type
of content inside the group so if you
are the person running the group if
you're the leader of the group
you need to have a strategy just having
a group to have a group
doesn't actually help people grow so
when you decide to open up your facebook
group and you want to lead a group
within
a niche you want to make sure that
you've got some type of a content plan
or some type of a plan
for people to be able to connect with
each other that's a big piece of it
especially as a leader of a group and so
i would say you want to always be
promoting
always be promoting you might think like
you're talking about that one thing all
the time
but people need like 30 touch points
before they make a decision
and you need to express what is the
value why should someone
join that group uh when you look at like
tony tony is a part like he said of so
many different vegan groups
most people are very interested in a few
things that they want to go deeper in
and so you have to just know that that
some people aren't going to be
interested
but if you are selling a group meaning
you are wanting people to join that
group
you've got to let them know what the
value is and so
if you are um saying what the value is
of the group
but you're also really clear on what
type of content goes in there like in
tony's vegan groups they're not posting
about priuses
they're posting about vegan recipes
right so you want to make sure that it's
very
clear on who is actually joining the
group does that help
yeah that helps and i'm i'm gonna say
thank you so much i'm actually
from what you guys have given the value
you've gave has attracted more people
which is what you guys deserve for the
hard work you give
and i'm actually um i'm releasing a
brand new influencers business on
october 16th
so excited awesome well congratulations
aidan you are
so much you're a think super fan hey did
you get that book in the mail
oh yeah it's right here awesome
yes got that in here little product
placement i love it thanks so much for
being on tonight aiden
yeah thank you man every time i see a
young hustler you know tony
yeah i know i know and i would encourage
you guys to this like
some of you guys might be like okay wait
so i have to start my own group
i would actually encourage you if you're
just starting especially on a certain
youtube channel
like just use like just go into other
people's groups because
whenever you start something it requires
so much attention and energy to get
momentum
that i want you to focus on your youtube
channel especially if you're under a
thousand subscribers i want you focusing
everything on building that
just try to you know attach on to some
of bigger groups that already
established
yeah that is such a great point and um
we know aiden's history we know he is a
hustler we know he's really about
really growing that influence but aidan
that's the tip right there tony just
gave you
be in the community you know there's a
book um
where is it seth godin oh here it is
[Music]
seth godin tribes you're right you saw
heather under sweatpants it's a matching
sweatsuit okay
seth godin tribes this is a great book
all about
tribes and if you've not gotten this one
gotten
if you've not purchased this one i
highly recommend it um because
it talks about doing exactly that tony
you know the idea of facebook groups
isn't that much different than you know
when people
go and like uh harley davidson they got
my grandpa's a part of a harley-davidson
group i don't know if he's on facebook
on a harley davidson group
but he is a harley davidson ride or die
guy and so he goes out and they do these
rides together and
so the idea of groups and subgroups and
niches
that's not just a facebook internet
thing that's been like
happening for a long time and so when
you can understand
the idea that you plugging into and get
this
being someone who is helpful being
someone who
is there for other people not for
yourself
it comes back to you twofold so because
tony spends hours tony how much time
a week do you spend being someone just
giving out information inside of groups
i think we need to talk about that
before we go into some other questions
yeah so me and my wife we do very much
spend hours
um we will be on our phones at night you
know before we go to bed wherever and we
will
be going to the facebook groups just
giving value just like trying to like
answer
questions in there um we're just trying
to be giving help and
yeah we're looking also for posts that
ask specific questions
that we have videos for so in a way
we're looking for how can we give value
answer questions
and give links to our videos and here's
the here's the extra thing i didn't even
share in
the presentation earlier is that you are
you starving for like video ideas
these groups will give you some of your
best video ideas i mean these groups
literally
we so many people asked what's the best
vegan coffee creamer
so many people asked it that we were
like let's just make that video because
that i just could already see how we
could
answer people's questions with that
video and so
that these groups i'm just i cannot be
more fan for you and your channel
to get video ideas to get exposure to
get people
onto your youtube channel and to be
extremely helpful it's amazing
that is one of the best tips did you
hear that think marketing that tip right
there
was key if you're struggling trying to
figure out what videos to make
right there inside of the groups is
exactly where you should go really uh
really great advice tony on just being a
part of
the community all right well i'm gonna
bring uh i i'm gonna bring someone on
he's gonna tell me how to say his name
and we are keeping the topic all around
facebook groups um tonight so
hey how you doing hey hi
what's your name and what's your channel
about well my name is inman slimer
i i'm a youtube talk show host
and yeah what i do is i basically tell
real news facts
and i bring people on my show
awesome well you are here and i know you
are also uh
man we've got the the uh young think
next
gen in the house and i want to just
thank you so much for being
on all of our streams i know you're
always here with questions so
what questions you have for tony and i
tonight well
yeah just like aiden said i'm also a
hype person
and yeah so yeah i'm a youtube talk show
host and
i upload every week at 7 pm easter so
yeah
so does promote works like on discord
facebook twitter etc yes tony how about
that question for a
man that's a great question so he was
asking basically
how we promote how to promote videos for
his channel
and i think when he's mentioning discord
if you're not familiar with that that is
basically like
it's a very gaming uh community but it's
basically you have your own servers and
you can
have a community in there and it's very
very powerful
my brother who runs a gaming channel has
a discord server of like 500 people 600
people
every time he posts a video he's able to
share in that discord and do those
things but
here's what i would say for promoting
your videos here's here's my tips for
you because here's the thing
promoting and marketing i mean i don't
know if you can let me in the chat does
that just overwhelm you that thought of
like i know it does for me i'm like wait
so i gotta be on like all these social
medias i gotta do all this stuff
so here's in man what i would encourage
you with is this
i want you to pick your one to two one
to two places you want to promote first
and i want you to do that consistently
so maybe it's discord for you if you
have a discord server
um i would just encourage you to utilize
that for sure um but maybe that is
facebook for you maybe you know gaming
gaming is there is gaming things in
facebook but you have to be really
specific around certain games
don't go into like streaming facebook
groups a lot of those end up being sub
for sub view for view and those kind of
things
so i would encourage you like someone
said earlier you can jump into reddit or
you could jump into discord
or even twitter is a huge gaming
community and so i would pick when
you're trying to promote your videos
you want to be picking the one to two
there um
platforms that you feel like are gonna
be where your audience hangs out the
most because i just can't tell you
i can't emphasize it enough is that when
you're starting a youtube channel and
you have nobody watching
right you have no one watching like you
have your brother and your dog watching
right i mean like
you just have nobody watching your
videos i cannot
tell you enough that yes ranking videos
that we talk a lot about here at think
marketing i think media is really
important
meaning ranking them in search when
people type in the search they find your
video
but let me tell you this that you know
even working at think media
and i rank videos for a living it still
took us
almost 30 videos to get our first ranked
video
on my wife's channel now could happen
sooner for you
it's not that that's like a metric but
i'm just trying to tell you that you got
to get creative about how you promote
your videos especially early on
so think about your one to two platforms
again for us facebook groups and i would
think for a lot of you guys i'm telling
you now
facebook groups are an untapped medium
for you and so that's what i would
encourage you with in man
with promoting your videos yes and i
love bringing them on tony
um let me know in the chat are you on
all of our lives i think
my favorite thing about the youtube
community tony is getting to see
you know people in the chat who we get
to see on all of the different lives so
let me know
are you always here on our lives um let
me know in the chat and then if you're
getting value out of this
make sure you hit that like button and
the subscribe button
if you would like uh other trainings
like this that we do here on
the think show all right i am going to
bring on i'm going to make
i'm going to bring her on i'll let her
introduce herself
hi how are you hi heather and tony my
name is nadja tony
i have i have a vegan restaurant in
baltimore so this is this is perfect
i have a question about advertising to
facebook's groups and i use um
the business manager for facebook and i
always have an
issue with uh facebook groups
not being able to advertise to what what
what are the strategies and how do you
advertise to those groups
yeah really great question uh nadja am i
saying that correct
yes yes okay really great question and
this is really about the paid strategy
for advertising to groups correct
yes because um i'll have 12 you know
they have the streams and all those
different
uh ways to advertise and facebook groups
will be the only one that's
x'ed out i can't do video ad or
something like that and i can't figure
it out
yeah it's not just you it actually is
just not part of what facebook allows
um is that is kind of like the last
sacred space
inside of facebook groups so the
strategy actually
is to um is because you can run
facebook ads to your own facebook
engagement
if some if you can pull people out of
the group and actually have them
be engaging with you on facebook then
then you can promote to that specific
person um so yeah facebook groups is the
one
piece uh there are companies out there
that allow you
to um it's almost like a third-party um
um api which is a fancy way of saying a
third party to connect two things
together
um yeah i actually i we do not um
there's none of those parties that i
would recommend
because they're pulling data that uh is
not actually been
allowed to be given out if that makes
sense so it is
a part of their policy but i do not
recommend purchasing lists of groups
um but facebook definitely does have
a lot of ways you can advertise but
groups is not
yet one of them okay so it's just not me
thank you because you confirmed it
just you and um hey tell us about your
restaurant so if anyone's in baltimore
they can head there
yes it's the land of kush and land of
kush.com
is the website we are an award-winning
vegan soul bistro and we're coming up on
10 years
so vegan soul food i'm going to open a
place and open up a place in la and
we'll be there i mean
my wife eat out of places like that all
the time so we will be
uh yeah what's your youtube channel
oh uh not just speak so it's n-a-i-j
speaks and i cover live interviews
on people events food and culture
amazing well thank you so much for being
on today
bye oh man tony let's go to baltimore
i know right i was like i'm kind of it's
almost dinner time here i'm like i don't
know what you heard i'm like i'm
starting to feel it a little the
rumble's ready to go
so yeah julie asked if she had a website
yep that's right julie and you could put
the pixel that's correct yep so there's
all different ways to advertise
that actually tony is what we teach
inside of inner circle one of the steps
that we teach
inside of inner circle which is our
monthly group coaching and mentorship
program
one of those is actually run ads to
scale and and that is actually through
the ten steps that we teach
in the six to seven figure media company
and if you're interested
you can go to think innercircle.com uh
enrollment is closing tonight it was
supposed to close yesterday but the
website was down and so we decided to
extend that out for you
so if that's something you're interested
in ongoing coaching from myself
sean cannell tony ariola melissa caputo
and the rest of the think
team this is the place to go if you want
that ongoing coaching well
uh go ahead and hit that like button
we've got a couple more questions that
came
in tony um but i want to know tony uh
when you say sometimes it can be hard to
rank the videos
i don't want to talk about ranking but i
just want you to encourage those people
you know a lot of people clicked on this
today
because they are identifying with being
under a thousand subscribers so what
encouragement would you give to people
who are taking notes who are ready who
want to grow but are feeling
stuck at that under a thousand
yeah i wanna tell you that you're not
alone like
a thousand is a big breakthrough moment
and here's the thing
anything that gets started at the start
it's slow it takes time to build
momentum
and it takes time to build what you see
here
at think media or in other channels that
you look up to
i would encourage you to find a few of
those channels that are big in your
niche that you look up to right
and look back at their first videos i
look back at those early days for them
and what that was like
but i want to encourage you with this is
that very much like
fishing right you have to you have to
you're
leaning in to learn the ways and it's
about putting in
a debate one extra time casting out the
reel and i'm not a fisherman so
by casting out the real one more time
right continue to cast the reel just do
it one more time
just do it one more time and you build
consistency
and you're gonna see results i just know
it like it's just building consistency
and you're going to see those results
and i just would encourage you to
to get around people that will speak
life into you that's one of the things
we try to do here
at think media and think marketing is
give you guys encouragement speak life
into you because here's the thing
like i mean like just being honest with
you guys when me and my wife are doing
this channel like
my wife was just like struggling for a
bit just going like man this is so hard
like i just feel like people don't care
when i release a video
and she just very transparently felt
that way and you know she spent her
whole weekend
you know doing videos let me know if you
can relate to that if you're working a
full-time job
and then on the weekends you're trying
to shoot videos you're trying to get
them edited you're trying to get them
you know ready to go and thumbnails and
you know announcing them on social media
platforms and it's just
it's intense right and then to see no
views come through it's
super disheartening but i guess i would
tell you this
that i want you to keep doing it one
more time and you know
the lack of views yeah that's
discouraging that's why you have to
surround yourself with
encouraging voices encouraging things so
find the things that get you pumped up
maybe it's our podcast you know we have
a podcast and you can check it out think
marketing podcast
you know maybe it's someone else's
podcast maybe it's you know there's
something
one speech that always inspires me and
i'll give you guys a little insight is
i think it's arnold schwarzenegger's
like seven keys to success i think it is
and sometimes i'll just like if i'm
feeling down
i know i can like kind of put that on
and it'll kind of just re-energize and
refocus me so
before your well gets empty you know and
maybe you're inspired ready
like take care and prepare for seasons
where you're gonna feel drained you're
gonna feel discouraged
so that in those times you can go to
those things that
refill up your motivation your
inspiration to keep pressing
record yes so good tony resonating with
those
in the comments right now uh that is the
truth right getting around people being
in those facebook groups and just
being surrounded with other people who
love what you're doing and
um so many people are resonating with
that message we've got one
more think marketing uh viewer on today
and it looks like we've got is
it vashna it's um it's actually vaishna
vaishna welcome to the think marketing
show how are you
i'm good i'm good i actually um also
attended the youtube influence challenge
so i learned a lot thank you so much for
the tips awesome hey tell us who you are
and what your channel is about and let
us know your question okay
um so my channel name is handmade by
vaishna
i'm an arts college and lifestyle
youtuber
i recently just started like a year ago
and
i'm i'm just trying to like figure out
what sort of content i want to do
and just sort of like get into the
momentum
so my question was um so i'm
i also joined like a facebook group as
well recently and i was wondering um
like should i join a niche specific
group
if the group that i'm in has almost
like 200k plus
people in it and would that benefit my
channel
yeah so what what uh so you're
what's the facebook group that you're in
what's the title of the facebook ground
um
i think it's called small youtubers
boost okay
something along the lines totally so
what i would encourage you is this
with this facebook groups group strategy
it's about finding your audience
okay and so i would care to imagine that
probably other small youtubers
probably isn't your real audience you
know so it's it's
the facebook group strategy really works
well when you find your audience so you
were saying
what's kind of like your your like
lifestyle channel what are some of like
your
your main topics you cover yes um so
i i am mainly so actually the way
i like kind of organize it was like
arts that's what i say first is like the
most import like the most important the
most prominent
college it's because i'm a college
student so i have
posted a few college vlogs and that's
happened to
blow up a little so i'm really happy
about that and then the lifestyle was
um it's just what i'm planning to do
it's like
it's just going to be kind of like
organizational stuff but it's like
it's like kind of in the works i have
posted like one or two videos but like
it's not really as prominent yet but
that's basically
the three niches that i'm hoping to
target
okay amazing so what i would encourage
you with is this then
with facebook groups think about you
know
those niches or those people you're
trying to serve and try to find groups
where those
those people are hanging out right so
like thinking about arts
is it like when you do arts and is it
like arts and crafts is it
like what kind of art is it it's like
it's like diy
kind of and like painting um greeting
cards like handmade greeting cards
okay gotcha okay so let me i'm just
doing a little bit of
searching here to see if i can help you
out with something real quick um
okay so here's a great example of this
right here i found one already
so these are the kind of groups if
you're going after that these are the
kind of groups you want to look at
okay is right here you can see and maybe
you guys can see on my screen i'll kind
of blow it up here so you can see a bit
more
oh wow that's quite a lot of good stuff
makes tips and all creation
greeting card hero vintage greeting
guard art card making
38 000 like these are the kind of groups
you want to be in because what happens
is you make a card making tips or or
like an arts and crafts thing and you
can
you know people are asking hey what are
like your halloween gift
like greeting card ideas right oh i have
a video right here
that talks about that you can comment
back to them hey i i made a few here
that you might like to check out
and what's even better to be honest like
the way that we utilized it is if you
had a few pictures of it
so you put the pictures in there right
hey these are some of the ones i made
um you can check them out here in the
photos i also have a full tutorial in a
video right here
oh wow okay that makes that makes it a
lot more
like clickable i mean when i'm trying to
imagine it that sounds a lot better
right and so that's the kind of thing
you want to do when you're looking at
the groups is look at
the people that are discussing your
topic like where are they talking about
stuff like right there we saw there was
like probably three or four groups what
i would do if i were you just join
as many as you can and you know we even
will post
older recipes you know and like well it
doesn't matter if like you're like oh i
posted this video like a month ago and
but it's still relevant to this person's
question and that's where i would
encourage you
um to start at right there so hopefully
that was helpful yeah
thank you so much thank you absolutely
absolutely
powerful tip tony's bringing up the
desktop showing the groups hey
think marketing here's your action step
we want you to join five groups tonight
so
after you're done watching this video
you're gonna go over to facebook
and you want to join five groups
that's gonna give you like tony said the
option to be able to talk to a lot of
different people and seeing
what groups you vibe with and what
groups really need your help and what
groups are active just because there's a
group doesn't mean that people are
active in it
so you want to make sure that you were
going over there and you were joining
the groups and hey
if you have not subscribed yet here at
the think marketing
show you want to make sure that you hit
that subscribe button for all
of the upcoming episodes and lives just
like this where you can join us you can
come on
and you can ask us your questions we so
appreciate you
i am just so honored to be able to be
here with you
and while you are walking through your
youtube journal journey
stay close to us here at think and you
can do that again by subscribing here or
by going over and joining our inner
circle you can get all the details
at think innercircle.com and if you want
to watch the next video in this
uh series or the next video on this
channel
you can just click on the screen right
now and it'll take you right over there
thanks so much for watching and we'll
catch you on the next video
bye